- Okay. I look okay?
- [Interviewer] You look great.
- Okay cool.
- [Interviewer] Okay. Emily,
Emily, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from
- Okay, So I grew up in Tacoma, Washington
which is just outside of
Seattle, Washington so,
- [Interviewer] Tell me about your family.
You had both your parents as a kid?
- No, my mom was a single mom growing up
and it was pretty hard.
I had a lot of issues with
seeing my parents fight.
My dad lived in Vegas
and my dad was in and out of our lives
and always physically
like violent with my mom.
And it was really rough
because I was the only child
and I was alone a lot.
So my mom had to go to
work and leave me alone
and it was really, it was
really lonely, you know, so
but then later on she met my
stepdad and then my stepdad
he came into my life when I was eight
and him and I never got along
so I had like real serious
issues with men, you know
not being accepting like
of me since a young age.
That really like threw
me off, you know? So,
- [Interviewer] It
still affects you today?
- Yeah. Big time. Big time. So, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Any, any abuse or?
- Well, throughout my whole life
I've had a lot of sexual abuse.
It started when I was a little
girl, when I was with my mom
I had friends that I was hanging out with
when I was like four and five,
and they were being sexually
molested by their stepfather.
And so they were coming
to hang out with me
and they were also touching me
because of showing like what
their father did to them,
They were passing it on to me.
And so I started touching
myself at a very young age,
like, like around five
I started like constantly
like touching my,
you know taking my
underwear off at daycare.
I was getting kicked out of daycare.
I was always trying to, you know
touch private parts and stuff.
It became really like a serious problem.
My mom was like really
embarrassed and I didn't know
what I was doing
I remember not knowing why
it was such a big deal.
And I would be like touching
my, you know what I mean?
Trying to like, and I was
having like orgasms, like
at a young age cause I was
doing it, you know, until I was
you know, done, you know what I mean?
And, but it was like a stress relief
and it's like embarrassing, but
yeah, I would get in trouble
and like spanked and stuff,
but I had to hide it, you know?
but I was like a chronic
masturbator when I was younger so,
you know, but I it's just
from sexual abuse, you know?
And then over time, you
know, like being so sexually
like intrigued, like in
porn and all that stuff
I was always looking for
like sexual, you know
things to get in like porn and
magazine, anything, you know
and experiences with people.
So it led to a lot of rape also,
you know, or falling asleep
and waking up with the
wrong people, you know
which is kind of like
something that I don't
consider like rape a lot.
And I never reported because
I put myself in the position.
So, you know? But yeah, a lot of,
a lot of sexual trauma for sure.
You know? So,
- [Interviewer] And when
did drug use come into you?
- [Emily] Drug use actually
came in later in my life
because I was actually pretty,
I thought normal, you know?
Until I was 27 and I started using drugs
when my husband had went
to jail and I was just mad
and I met a girl that I was
in went to high school with,
and she was using meth
and we started using meth
and I haven't stopped since.
- [Interviewer] And how do
you support yourself now?
- I support myself by escorting
on the streets of Los Angeles.
And it's not a totally bad job.
I've lost a lot of my connection
with my family though,
and I have no friends really at all
because girls don't respect me
and men kind of look at me like
as a little bit lower level, you know?
Just as a sex object,
but the money I make is really
good and I can support myself
and other people, you know?
And I get it really fast
but the downside there's a lot
of downsides to it as well.
But right now that's the only thing
I can really function in and do
- [Interviewer] How much do you make
- [Emily] while am a drug addict
- [Interviewer] How much
do you make a night or day?
- [Emily] Right now I'm making like up to,
like two to 300, but I
,when I was in my like prime
and doing not so much drugs
cause right now the drugs
have kind of taken over.
I am a heroin addict and
stuff and crystal addict and
before I was so deep into it
I was making a thousand
dollars a day easy, you know?
And it was really, I was
really proud of myself
and excited about having a pimp
and these men that were so into me
because growing up I was
really not attractive.
I was fat and I was just not accepted
by the boys that I went
to high school with.
And, you know?
And so when I started realizing
men were kind of attracted
to me when I was older,
I just was, you know?
Especially with all that sexual, you know?
Like a curiosity so I just was, you know?
Prostitution became
like a fun thing for me
that I was proud of I felt
good that men wanted to pay
to be, like around me, you know?
When I didn't care who they were
but they weren't actually
paying to, you know, be with me.
So it made me feel like, you
know, worth, you know, so,
- [Interviewer] So it's a little
bit of a self-esteem boost
- yeah
- [Interviewer] but it also kind of
undermines your self-esteem
- Right, right its weird.
- [Interviewer] At the same time
Yeah it's very weird, yeah.
It's. It's like bad
days can be really bad.
Like some days I can
have where men are not
like I go up to the, to their
car or, you know, respond
to them and they see me and
they're like, Oh, nevermind.
You know, that can really
hurt my (indistinct)
you know, and that just
makes me feel like shit
or other times when the guys
is like, you're awesome.
You're beautiful.
You're so gorgeous.
You know?
And I'm just like, yeah, but it's like
I lived through what they feel about me.
You know?
I don't have the confidence in
myself, you know? By myself.
I have to know what
they're thinking about me
and that's how I feel at that time.
So yeah
- [Interviewer] Have
you worked with a pimp
- Yeah I do right now.
I've been on and off my
whole career doing it.
I've been through a lot of terrible pimps,
but right now hopefully it's good
because usually when I work by myself
I don't make at all the amount
of money I do with the pimp.
A pimp, you know, keeps you
on track, keeps you doing it.
You know like when I'm by myself
I just get like 20, 40 bucks.
And then I go out and do dope.
And then, you know, I get lazy.
I don't do half the shit
It's like, when there's somebody there
watching you do what
you're supposed to do,
I do it better cause I want
to show off anyways and stuff,
and I just want to be like,
look I'm the cool girl that
can bring in all this money.
But when I'm by myself, I'm like, eh!
- [Interviewer] Cause you
still, you're still bringing him
all the money?
- Yeah I give him everything.
- [Interviewer] What are the,
some of the terrible stories
you've had (inaudible)
- Well, I had a concussion
because I got my head kicked
in really bad for being out of pocket
because I was telling one
of his other girls that
I missed my old like boyfriend
- [Interviewer] Out-of-pocket is what?
- Out of pocket is when,
with the whole in a pimp
when you're doing
something that is not okay.
Like there's a list of
rules, strict rules like
that we follow, you know,
and if we ever do, you know
something that is out
of pocket which means...
when you're in pocket
that means you're doing the
right thing by your dude.
You know, like not looking at, or talking
to other men, not flirting, not
doing anything that can lead
up to something that would
be disloyal or, you know
like bring the other.
But you're always trying to, you know
make your pimp like the better person.
You don't want to bring money
to another dude or, you
know, involve anybody else.
You want to make that guy the best.
You know what I mean?
I don't know if that makes
any sense, but you know
but being out of pocket is serious.
Like it can range from just
looking at another man,
you know in the eyes to
you know, like giving another man money.
That's super serious so
- [Interviewer] So you got
your concussion at one point
- Yeah I was on the, I was
just, I was on the ground
scrubbing the floor and he walked in
and I was like, you know, Hey, what's up?
You know
And he came in and he was
like, Hey, how's it going?
And I was like, you know, like fine.
And then he just kicked me
hard as hell, like in my head.
And I was, I had blood
coming out of my ear
and I had never, that was the first time
I ever got hit by anybody you know,
like, not even my ever ,like
the people in relationships
that were boyfriends
you know, but this guy kicked me
and then he started like
punching me all because
I had told his other whore
that I missed the guy
that I was with prior to him, you know
not that I was going back, you
know, just that I missed him
that I, you know, I had
feelings for him, you know
because the guy I was with
at the time that kicked me
I had no romantic feelings for
It was just a work relationship.
But because I was saying that to her, she
she ran behind my back
and told him because she wanted to look
like a better girl, you know, in front
of his eyes, by snitching,
which is called whore games.
It's terrible but, yeah.
So yeah, but I had a concussion
and that was like the
beginning of my beatings.
And then I got started
getting beat a lot after that
which is so weird because
I actually was a really
in pocket whore compared
to a lot of other girls
it's just that they would
sense my submissiveness.
And they thought that a lot of them
that I chose to be with
were just not good guys
at all, you know?
And they would see the weakness
and they would prey upon it.
Like I remember waking up
to like being like punched
and beaten and stuff.
And for no reason, like
I just made my quota
making money all night and I needed rest.
And I remember waking
up to getting my beat
Like, to get out of bed, that sucks,
that's a terrible way
to wake up, you know?
And you feel like about yourself.
So, and you don't understand
why you're trying to
do everything right.
And you know, this is, you know
kicking your, you know, so,
but that's just, you know
their, their problems,
you know, but it's hard for whores
because when we meet a
man that says, he's a pimp
he's supposed to be God to us.
He's supposed to be like everything.
We're supposed to listen
to him and he's never
supposed to be wrong.
So it's us that are always wrong.
So if we try to, you know,
tell him like in a relationship
with a man and a woman, a wife
and a husband that is equal
with a pimp and a whore,
the whore is always the one
in the wrong, no matter,
even if she's right.
You know what I'm saying?
So it sucks when you have a
person that you're working
with who is extremely abusive,
mental ill, mental illness is involved,
you know, drug addiction for them.
So that's when things can get really ugly
and people can get killed or go to jail so
- [Interviewer] Have
you had bad experiences
with your customers as well?
- Oh yeah, yeah, Definitely.
I mean, customers are
actually usually better
But I have had a lot of, yeah
bad experiences, but I've learned a lot.
In the beginning I went
through a lot of sh... you know
stuff that all whores go through, you know
learning how to protect ourselves right?
Like always making sure they wear condoms
cause they try to not
wear, they it's so crazy
How many guys that are
normal men that have wives
and children, and working,
you know the society
that are regular people,
you know, people that
you know, are doctors,
lawyers, they have, you know
families and they come to me
and they want to, you know
use no condom, which is called bareback.
We call it bareback.
They don't want, they want
to be able to, you know
like cum inside our like
on our bodies and you know
in our bodies, which is like, you know
illnesses like AIDS, everything,
you know what I mean?
Or in our mouths, you know?
And they think because they're
they're experiencing something that
they're not going to
get anything, you know,
they're like immune but
that's not how it works.
You know what I mean?
So like, it's just crazy how many
like regular normal men want to
give the risk of getting diseases?
Cause the girls that work
we're totally not trying
to not work on them.
Do you know what I mean?
So it's them because they, you know
don't wanna experience that the feeling of
plastic or whatever, but it's crazy
how many people have AIDS out here in LA
and it's really scary, you know
because they offer you so
much more money for no condoms
and stuff, but you gotta
just be stronger, you know?so
- [Interviewer] Do you have children?
- Do I have children? I
have three, three kids.
That's the biggest thing
I regret in my life
is that I wasn't a good mom, you know?
Cause like I really love
my kids so much, you know,
- [Interviewer] Where are they?
- I have, I have two
of them are with my mom
in Seattle-Tacoma area
and they are my son.
My first born is Zavian,
he's eight years old.
And my daughter Elica who is six
and I have a three-year-old here in LA,
who is ,his, name is Acharitu.
And he is, he's half Mexican.
And yeah, I don't get
to see them very much,
but, when I'm with them, it's like, great.
Like I'm like the happiest
person. It's just,
I have this drug addiction to where like
when I'm with them, I can be the best mom.
But then when I start to need drugs,
Its like things that the
drugs come before them.
And it's not like I want to
put the drugs before them
but it just, I can't like,
you know, so it's like
something I regret so much, you know?
Cause I love them so much
and I don't want them to
ever think that I chose drugs
over them, you know, but
- [Interviewer] Where's your third child?
- My third child's here
in South central LA.
- [Interviewer] With (inaudible)
- With the parents of my
boyfriend that I had down here
I was with the, the father
for the last five years so,
- [Interviewer] Does
your family know you're
- Yeah
- [Interviewer] out here doing this?
- Yeah, they don't talk to me anymore
because they don't approve
of my lifestyle, you know?
so, and I lost a lot of
well connection with all
my family and it's crazy
Cause we used to be really
close and I just lost my aunt
to a brain tumor and it
was really hard cause it's
I didn't get to say
goodbye cause she wouldn't,
you know she didn't want to talk to me,
and nobody wanted to talk to me,
because they are very strict,
you know, they don't believe
in drug addiction and
prostitution or anything.
They think I'm like crazy.
And the fact that is they think
that I am doing this
because I choose to do it.
Like every day I wake up and I'm like
Oh my family or this,
you know what I mean?
Like really I would choose my family
but my addiction is something
that is so strong right now
that it takes over, you
know, precedent over my life.
You know what I mean?
Like it's just like such a
strong, like when I get sick
with heroin and I'm dope
sick, I become so sick
that I wish I was dead
sometimes, you know, like instead
of being sick and I'll do
anything to get well, you know?
I've done some really
to make sure that I never got sick.
You know? So like
- [Interviewer] Do you find,
do you find the line that
you're willing to cross
changes as you
- Definitely versus when
I'm have dope and stuff?
I'm a lot more in control,
but when I don't have dope
and I don't know where I'm
going to get my next issue
or my next amount of money
I've, you know, put myself
in positions that were extremely
immoral, you know, like not
- [Interviewer] What's, what's, what's
the most extreme thing you've ever done.
- The most extreme thing
I've done is I, I had sex
with like two different
guys at the same time.
And it was just for
like a little tiny piece
of like black, you know,
just like a shot of black,
that would only last me
like for like an hour or so
you know, but I was so sick
and you know, and they just
I just kind of like, you know, there
it was just one like,
you know, from the front
one from the back and it
was just at the same time
and it was really rough
and you know, it was just
I let them like just use my
body for whatever, you know
and I just was not wanting
to be sick, you know?
And it's something I regret
very much, but I just, I
I'm not going to lie if I had to
I would do it again to
make myself not sick
because being sick and feeling for that
when you know that you're
so sick and you're like
can't even get up to go to the bathroom
and you're yourself and you are like, just
you feel like, you like, and you know
that one little piece of dope
that's like tiny is, you know
it doesn't even have to be a lot
just a little tiny bit and
you, you know, put it back
into your veins and it makes
you a completely, well again
like every symptom gone
and you can function to completely normal
like even better than our normal human.
Like when I do that dope,
I don't have no pain.
I can go for hours, you know, walking.
Like I don't have no,
no issues with my knees.
Like I used to, you know,
like all my pains go away
so I can do things that like, you know
like a superhuman and
then, so that's probably
why when I do get sick,
it hurts so bad too
because my body is going
so high up with the dope.
And then it shoots back down so bad
that it's like one extreme to the other
and it's really, you know,
a tough life to live really.
So.
- [Interviewer] What would
you, what would you say
to your family and kids if
they happen to see this?
- Just sorry (sobbing)
I really wish that they would've
not turned their back on me
you know
because you know
I wish they would have
been more patient, you know
not just like said, you know
handle it yourself because
the craziest thing too is
like my drug addiction to
opioids really started, you know
I don't mean to like put my
mom out there, but my mom
and I started using opioids
together when I was just
after my first C-section
by we were abusing the
painkillers and stuff.
And I never really looked at
it as like drug use at all.
Cause we were using painkillers
but my art addiction became so strong
we were buying 30 milligram
pills off the streets
and we were going home and
being like grandma and mom.
So I didn't feel it as doing drugs.
Like how, when you smoke crystal
or do drugs in the
streets, you're out here.
You know, because when I
was doing drugs with my mom
we were always like doing drugs
so we can be a better family, you know
cause we couldn't function
around each other when we didn't have it.
So, when we would get high
together, like it was, you know
just super good family time
and my son would be so excited, you know
because all of a sudden
we'd be high feeling good
and we would be so fun, you know
and we'd get on the ground playing.
And then when we didn't have the drugs
like my son, you know, we'd
have to sit and watch TV
while we felt bad, you know,
or my mom would lay in bed
and stuff or I'd lay in bed and you know
like it was just one extreme to the other.
And my mom ended up losing her job
from being a parole officer.
She had worked there for
23 years and they found out
because she was showing
up so high every day
and carrying a gun.
So they had to do an interview
and, you know, she got fired
and everything and it was
really hard on the family.
And so that's why they
blame me a lot because
they feel like I was the
one providing her the drugs
and when she lost her job,
she lost a lot of, you know
the her, her persona,
persona and everything
that she worked for.
And so the family kind
of blamed that on me and
because my mom, after she lost
her job, she went to rehab
got clean and took the kids.
When I chose to keep
continuing using drugs,
I didn't go to rehab and stuff.
So, I stayed getting
worse and worse, you know
while everybody was like trying
to help my mom and my kids
and stuff, which I really
appreciate more than anything
that they took my kids
and took care of them.
And they did so much
better than I could have.
You know, I just, I
just wished that things
would've worked out a little
bit different, you know?
So
- [Interviewer] What do you think
most people that don't
do hard drugs like this
don't understand about addiction?
- They think that we
are like losers and that
we choose to do this.
A lot of us are extremely
intelligent, educated.
Like I have my college
degree, like I'm extremely
intelligent.
I know, you know, a lot of things
I just have issues with
like self esteem, depression
you know, I'm trying to use
these drugs to not feel like
you know, sad, you know, I
would just want to be happy
you know and like be normal.
But the drugs in the beginning,
they made us feel normal
you know?
But as you go further
and further, you don't
it doesn't become normal.
It becomes extremely messed up.
And you start to lose your, your mind.
You know, you lose everything,
your family, your mind
I just don't ever do drugs.
You know, if you're cool
and you don't need drugs
don't do them because
once you start doing any
you develop an addiction,
you'll have it the rest
of your life, even if you become clean.
So, it's not something
you want to get, you know
- [Interviewer] Thank you so
much for sharing your story.
- Sorry, yeah, it's a
little bit emotional.
Sorry I've started to cry
and talk at the same time
- [Interviewer] No
thank you for sharing it